its second day June Tuesday you watching
gamespot news I'm Chris waters and I'm
wondering is it III yet because with
XCOM 2 announced yesterday and two new
rumor teaser things in today's show
scenes like publishers really want it to
be III like now it's kind of like when
Christmas decorations start appearing in
stores the day after Halloween we get it
you're really excited to sell us things
I guess publishers are just really
excited to tell us things things that
will now tell you the announcement of
Fallout 4 has been churning through the
rumor mills for years and with today's
launch of a countdown teaser website I
can confidently announced that tomorrow
I'll have something to announce fallout
Beth softcom is currently live and
ticking down the hours until wednesday
morning at seven a.m. pacific time a
line from the websites source code
contains a reference to Fallout 3's
master brain so it looks like tomorrow's
the day we finally get something solid
on fallout 4 until then you'll just have
to continue to subsist on wingnut
conspiracy theories like mine that the
game takes place after nuclear disaster
strikes the set of an 80s ski movie
chillin of all the game designers I've
had the pleasure of hosting on the live
stage at e3 over the years the only one
that people ever lined up to get
autographs from was hit ataka Miyazaki
he designed and directed demon's souls
Dark Souls and blood-borne and now he
might be back for dark souls 3 an
unconfirmed rumor reported by VG 24-7
claims that Namco Bandai I will announce
Dark Souls 3 at e3 this year and that
Miyazaki will be back at the head of the
development team after serving in a
supervisory capacity for dark souls 2
have you ever bought a steam game and
then played it for like 15 minutes and
then thought to yourself wow that was a
real bad call I'm terrible with money
that was a poor financial decision dang
well now you might go get your money
back valve today announced a refund
policy that allows you to return games
and dlc within two weeks of purchase
provided you haven't played the content
in question
for more than two hours all you need to
do is request the refund through steams
website and wait a week for approval
this seems exploitable and they've
basically just created a demo for every
game out there right some finer points
of the policy remain unclear but you can
read more about the details on gamespot
com / news and then let us know in the
comments how you plan to game the system
I mean use this feature in the spirit
that it was intended and finally the DC
Comics MOBA that lets you push lanes as
the flash and Green Lantern will be
going offline this summer Infinite
Crisis was in beta for an extended
period of time before its full release
just three months ago in March it was
met with lukewarm reception garnering a
six from GameSpot reviewer Tyler Hicks
no specific reason for the shutdown was
given in the announcement and turbine is
offering some refunds for paying players
on their steam page there's probably
some Infinite Crisis titled jokes to be
made here but I'm gonna steer clear out
of respect for the developers or because
I just can't think of a good 13 months
from full release to shut down
announcements and that is fast well such
is life in the breakneck world of video
game business I'll see you tomorrow as
business and the news march on